where do I start with this I think what
I'm going to do is I'm going to start
with an audio clip from the third video
in the sequence just so you can
you're the general tone and frame with
which uh people are sort of operating
Within
we've said this before it's a whole
negotiate uh with your spouse partner
wife whatever and
um it really just boils down through
trying to build a better beta but a lot
of what he's talking about relies on
both parties taking accountability which
I'll get into some of this stuff a lot
of my notes over here but I kind of want
to start this with just this audio intro
because he says something that's pretty
powerful
um research the third sequence of the
videos with
um what you're sacrificing to get
married so let me just play this I can't
play the whole thing or react to the
whole thing clip by clip because that
would um infringe on uh their IP and all
that sort of stuff so I'm gonna play
this quick little clip at like 20
seconds and there's just one two three
four five six seven eight nine very
powerful word words that he says in this
intro that I want you to hear in his
voice before I get into my reaction to
all the materials so let's get started
with that hopefully you can hear this
foreign
and then you think well what are you
sacrificing to get married well let's
think about it what is this opportunity
foolish juvenile short-sighted
nihilist cynical Psychopathic impulses
promiscuity that's what your
sacrification it's like hey you might
want to sacrifice that because that
sounds like a pretty decent collection
of demons and you probably don't want
that cluttering up your life that's
what's going to be all right so
there's your little intro so those words
again were
when you're sacrificing
marriage avoiding it specifically
foolish juvenile excited nihilistic
cynical Psychopathic impulsive and
promiscuous
um and he says it was for demons so
I'm not getting married instead because
that would be far better off for it and
I got a few things to say about that
um guys if you're just joining the
podcast do me a solid and um
YouTube on the general chat uh Facebook
Twitter Twitches twatches whatever do me
a solid click that link head over to
um YouTube and hit the like button
um And subscribe to the channel so
all right man I got so many notes in
this
there's a lot of disparaging words that
he's using to describe men that don't
get married
I don't get the impression he's talking
to women specifically with this although
he does appear to be speaking to both
parties when it comes to the sense of
negotiating and working with one another
so
here we go
um
one of the big problems that I find with
almost everything in this three-part
series and there was some good stuff so
I'm going to say that is that it relies
on both parties taking responsibility
and wanting to do the work
and there's some flaws with that which
I'll get into in a little bit but I
don't think it's entirely realistic in
the world that we live in today
um says marriage grows you up you become
an adult when you get married in the
series uh he says you're not mature
until somebody else matters more than
you meaning your kids
and by the way guys you don't need to
get married to have kids there's plenty
of people that have children that don't
invite the state into their life or live
in a way where the state would look at
their relationship as a marriage or move
to places where the state can't control
their life in the way that it does in
the west Canada you know certain states
in the U.S for example the UK and stuff
like that
um so some of the major flaws which I
bullet pointed here is he assumes women
will take accountability the way that
men do he says if cheat sheets in the
relationship recovery is based on your
ability to negotiate
which I mean look when
when men go outside of the relationship
they cheat when women go outside of the
relationship they betray it's two
different things and I've covered that
before in other videos
um I'm sure you guys are familiar with
that he one of the things that he admits
and I'm going to quote and end quote
this he stated a difficult custody again
you know this is in quotes a difficult
custody battle battle is equivalent to a
near fatal bout with cancer end quote
now
he's advocating for marriage he's saying
let's build a better beta you guys can
negotiate and figure it out you're not a
man until you have children he said if
you're not married by the time you're 40
or a creep those are you know his exact
words but then he also admits in another
breath that custody battles are the
equivalent of near fatal bouts with
cancer and 50 of the time people get
married after about seven to ten years
so you've got a 50 chance of basically
having a fatal bet with cancer I mean he
acknowledges that reality at least the
problem that I have with the entire
series he offers no real risk mitigation
techniques that I talk about in the
chapter in my book
um again I want both to have it over
here
yeah
um if you guys haven't got it the
unplugged Alpha is on Amazon
in print Kindle and audible I narrated
myself and
one of the longer chapters in my book
chapter 15 is title why smart man avoid
marriage I'm going to get into some of
this stuff in response to his
um points here that I made
so we talked about the difficult custom
battle admission uh he assumes both
parties will negotiate are mostly equal
and will take ownership he does not like
the idea of a woman submitting to a man
in a relationship
uh quote tyranny or slavery is what he
calls it end quote
when women yield to a man it seems so
he's of the opinion that men and women
are pretty much the same they're equal
and that they should negotiate amongst
themselves for the better outcome of the
the marriage you know the children blah
blah blah all that sort of thing so
everything he's talking about in this
series
if you're an alpha male you're an
unplugged alpha male it's not going to
be of any use to you whatsoever if
you're plugged in beta and you want to
become a better beta you might get
something out of it but you're real like
he's just going to March you into a
slaughterhouse with what he's given you
because there's no risk mitigation tools
whatsoever and we haven't seen
negotiating desire to be a successful
way uh to long-term happiness in
relationships
evidence-based at least okay
um you know as they say you simply
cannot negotiate desire it's got to be
genuine burning desire chapter three of
my book I talk about why genuine burning
desire matters
um he also another flaws he also takes
no consideration for the modern
landscape
um you know the dating landscape family
law
feminism a female promiscuity and the
weak state of men today as well because
the vast majority of men are are weak
like we know something like a third of
men today under the age of 30 30 or 33
or something like that I covered This
months ago but most men aren't being
intimate they're like they're not having
sex so if a girl comes along
you know she's been run through her 20s
she partied a foam Cannon party here and
there Ibiza Vegas that sort of stuff
whole bunch of guys under Notch counts
and all of a sudden she finds the
dutiful
accountant or uh you know good guy that
has a nice corporate gig that pays him
well
he's just good enough and she signs up
for that
um there's there's no accounting for the
weak state of men or their inability to
decipher good women from bad women
because
some reasonably hot woman touches his
pee pee and he likes it and she says
let's get married I want to have kids
and he says yeah let's do that
he's not betting her at all you know and
if he goes and watches something this is
just man up and don't be a [ __ ] and get
married
um it's it's a March into a
slaughterhouse so anyway I'll keep going
through some of these points here and
I'll take some call-ins on today's show
I'll I'll drop the join like you guys
can uh
um ask questions on the topic or um you
know if you got something you want to
ask it'll be open I'll try to make sure
I have enough time you know posted for
you guys and a few you guys mentioned
actually by the way when I posted it in
the community tab that um you'd like to
see me and Jordan Peterson have this
conversation or or a debate and a few
years ago I I've I think I've messaged
him at least twice
um to come onto my plane win podcast or
even my uh
uh before the train wreck before I
renamed it the unplugged Alpha
um I have a talk about you know his
expertise and uh he just ignored it so
the the invite's open
um you never took me up on it I did have
a conversation with um
what's his name from daily wire Andrew
Clavin they had a segment they were
doing on marriage or divorce it was
about a year ago you can find it on
Andrew Clayton Channel maybe search for
Andrew Clavin and Richard Cooper in the
YouTube search bar and you'll probably
see it but we had a a pleasant you know
20-minute conversation about the concept
of long-term relationships and
specifically marriage and divorce
um more obviously on different sides of
the uh topic but it was a productive
conversation you know there was there
was people that got something out of
that anyway hey guys I really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out